se lo dovesse ragazzi venuti a questo
video sono fa vj oggi siamo col buon
sasha è tornati su the forest sasha una
piscina di palline dietro di lui non
fate domande e io ho la tazza di
pailettes perché voglio giocarmela molto
easy vuoi o anche un rotolo di carta
igienica e per vedere più lontano e
spetta è manna va agli avvertivo fatto
un trick comunque ragazzi allora eravamo
rimasti che ci avevamo buttare nella
nella voragine che questa qua senti un
attimo non è come c'entriamo nella
voragine dobbiamo buttarci o cosa
dobbiamo fare august remo un ponte
oppure ci lanciamo con la slitta
dell'idea cazzo facciamo così ad anagni
o prenderla slitta e così almeno è
tornato intanto a casa che facciamo
giochini ma casa dormiamo prendiamo la
slitta e torniamo a belgio è la legge
della sopravvivenza non ci fa dormire
perché non ci fa dormire testa di
minchia su cosa ci va a dormire
ma ecco adesso mi fa dormire a caso fai
così ha scelto a cava bene ha deciso lui
quando a dormire ma perché sono i magi
capiscioni magi campi fuori nello stagno
corrie now
mi chiamo prima donna che brutalità ho
preso magica lo è che cosa stai facendo
non lo so sto nolo colpisco ma per chi è
collage la slitta allora dobbiamo fare
solo un test e visto che hanno
aggiornato il gioco nel mentre magari
non funziona più quella cosa che checco
quindi vuol dire che è corrosa devo
subire una bravo adesso proviamo
eh no se funziona funziona perfetto ha
detto ci ringraziato prendo io lo prendo
io forte ma mista al comando amori crepa
lo investito ma non è morto non si è
fatto niente ma mi ha compiuto la cometa
coppa ma cosa addio cattivissimo
ma no sei morto proprio sonora live e
allora facciamo così tanto la tua roba
allora facciamo così guarda la tua roba
tanto rimane qua visto che sei morto se
ti butto nella voragine meno se muori
non perdi almeno tutte le cose che avevi
perché sono rimasti qua giusto devi
andare a lavorare nei se ti ricordi più
o meno dove è seguito dalla mappa era
meglio solari costruivamo è infatti e
allora [ __ ] ricostruiamola beni
viene su di me vengo versato subito sono
partigiano su un fortissimo e vero non
stai attento dietro attento dietro euro
euro capitolo scappato da quello bravo
sasha teamwork porca [ __ ]
allora lo faccio questo tentativo perché
sono una persona coraggiosa mi butto
forte ma cosa stai dicendo
allora senti fallo privato che non è
niente ho fatto presente che non è
niente buttati potrebbe esserci
dell'acqua che noi non vediamo perché
non renderizza abbastanza quindi
potresti cadere su dell'acqua devi farlo
dove sei e penso che sono c'è un'altra
buca un altro buco un'altra caverna sei
morto
le dissi di sì schiantato per terra
quindi quando servirebbe minecraft un
bel secchio d'acqua e si scende a uso
una sedia
eccola che semmai è che va bene a ikea
non piace questi elementi visto che la
nara al central è impossibile prova la
fai un tentativo ancora tu che non hai
niente parolacce dai fallo per il popolo
parla oggi farà vedere come esplana
prova città sei morto a casa mi ha dato
di nuovo giù così suo odio odio fermo
però farò fermato il voto ci vivo kat
onorarono non giu però sono in un punto
dove posso ancora scendere aspetta porca
[ __ ] che ansia e mangiati le medicine
esatto mica sto facendo medicina in
medicina cosiddetta piano piano piano
benissimo e ci sta arrivando
cazzo tanti problemi no so mi sono
lasciata sola pagina
non ci posso credere a cena spettacolo
fatto no non ci sto ancora faceva spetta
sono o sono a buon punto è cazzo se
potessi salvare il co sarebbe affrontata
c'è un villaggio vicino a metà tra la
superficie ma come cazzo è odio trovato
la caverna segreta sasha devi venire qua
come ti aspetto di venire qua corri
aspetto vieni vieni fuori e vieni
bellissimo lascia lascia sasha cha cha
cha cha
niente ragazzi sono da solo lasciano
risponde sasha che problemi va bene
ragazzi facciamo questi consiglio nella
sua vita ce la posso fare ci sono due
entrate da qua ce n'è una che è quella
che vedete davanti credo sia un entrata
e ce n'è un'altra dalla parte opposta io
prima di entrare per apprendere il più
possibile di risorse vedete riesco a
trovare cose meno ci prepariamo al
peggio
che culo miche bengala perfetta ero già
pieno di bengala perfetto cosa c'è
lattine che cazzo ci fanno delle lattine
di birra quanti alla pesca va bene
allora facevo che mangiare gli snack
l'unica roba che vorrei fare prima di
era la madonna che culo ci sono anche le
1000 medicine mica fantastico ma è così
allora ragazzi l'unica roba che mi manca
prima di entrare ed è veramente solo una
e voglio provare a vedere se riesco a
fare un rifugio perché se riesco a fare
il rifugio almeno riesco a salvare la
partita qua sotto e sarebbe fantastico
veramente sarebbe perché sono migliori
fare tutto ed è impossibile devo mettere
rifugio al limite del bordeaux
dimmi che ci arrivano le foglie ci
arrivo ci arrivò con le foglie
ringraziando iddio meno male allora
mancano sette tronchi vuol dire che un
ragazzo li trovi rametti qua sotto e io
li ho visti prima sono qua tutti a terra
vi chiedete che cazzo ci fanno dei
rametti qua per terra non me ne frega
niente non me lo chiedo perfetto oddio
ci siamo ragazzi allora ci sono due
entrate questa qui è quella dove ci sono
le capanne io direi per cominciare di
vedere in teoria poi posso anche andare
volendo anche sotto potrei scendere pian
piano forse dovrei riuscire ad arrivare
al buco quindi abbiamo un sacco di
possibilità quando che siamo quindi la
prima cosa mi vien da fare visto che non
già un sacco di roba e entrare in questo
primo altro segreto si prova ragazzi
bear grylls mi fa una pippa era cani
anche il signore degli anelli permesso
non ho mai visto se caverne cioè non è
veramente siamo nelle caverne più
esistano sapete che se c'è qualche
problema io sono pure la sola non ce n'è
anche sasha che cazzo di problemi di
firenze bambini
porca ben consapevole grande vabbè
arriva l'ace vedo delle luci led e luci
oddio come faccio il suicidio ma dove mi
sono buttato perché su vivo sono vivo
sono vivo non ci posso credere michiara
una scena da film lega il son dovuto
buttar giù per salvarmi la vita e sono
ancora vivo non ci posso credere
ringraziando iddio trovato le medicine
sopra sono ero morto c'è un accordo c'è
una corda prova a salire io vi giuro
ragazzi che non ho mai vista una roba
così in the forest mai sono in una
caverna che non ho mai visitato in tutti
gli anni cui giocato a the forest oggi
attenzione che poi potrebbe tornare il
tizio che i bambini
ecco infatti porca [ __ ] sti bambini
merda dov'è il tipo dove tipo crepa
ok muori la mancanza sono centinaia
e vabbè questa è sporta vai giù come fai
a essere ancora vivo quanti siete
va bene
[Musica]
perfetto si sta roma c'è una spiegazione
un piccone ma chi è che va bene pure sul
piccolo ne ho preso devo salire col
piccone veramente ma corre da qua ma
veramente 9 non ci credono ma cazzo non
sapevo si potesse fa sta roba quanto
figo de force tra l'altro con quale
fisica è impossibile se riuscissi ad
aggrapparci a sta cosa sarebbe duro wow
prova che non ri e non fa niente se mi
sono entrate delle stalattiti in faccia
vero ce l'ho fatta
ci ho fatto effetto non c'è una torcia
un qualcosa porca eva no no no c'è un
tizio qualcosa da piccone posso farlo
fuori
air da ok un andato a pronunciare le
armi ragazzi l'ho mancato
ok gli ho dato fuoco alla mano non
amavano mastranzo perfetto ragazzi ce
l'ho fatta c'è c'è una corda la corda
una testa altro muro da scalare ma cosa
dire il posto salendo un sacco ragazzi
quindi secondo me prima o poi sbu che
remo da qualche parte li che va
benissimo perché almeno quando ritrovo
sasha riusciamo a scendere insieme sta
cosa va su per bene e come cazzo ci
arrivò alla spiega mente
non posso ma posso andare anche al lato
anche ne so io grandissimo vai fratello
fantastico ce l'ho fatta
altra corda poi ci stanno un bastone
degli snack perfetto c'è l'uscita
grandissimo se riesco a uscire l'acqua è
meraviglioso perché almeno quando arriva
a sasha possiamo farlo anche insieme
così andiamo avanti insieme perfetto
dove che sbuchiamo salve mi scusi non sa
io volevo solo dirle che mi sta un po in
culo però vabbè ragazzi devo segnarmi
assolutamente passiamo di fianco a casa
ma non è vero non ci credo mai quindi
voi di rito il collegamento alla
voragine vicinissimo a casa mia ma io
come faceva non saperlo porca eva
quindi ragazzi appena torna sasha la
cosa che possiamo fare è scendere nella
voragine insieme perché possiamo
scendere dalla corda
così almeno non abbiamo problemi e anche
molto meglio sta roba perché non devo
neanche segnarmi il punto perché è
vicinissimo c'è veramente ci arrivò a
piedi quindi ragazze a questo punto
direi di andare a salvare la partita
così che dalla prossima volta riusciamo
a ripartire da qua e andiamo
direttamente dentro la caverna andiamo
insieme vi ricordate che quando siamo
scesi nel punto questo qua c'erano due
vie c'era una sinistra una destra
io ho scelto quella a destra quella
vicina alle capanne quella in realtà era
per tornare indietro l'altra invece è
per andare avanti sicuro quindi ragazzi
dalla prossima sicuramente andiamo
avanti perché l'altra via è quella che
ti non ti porta soprana sotto quindi io
anche cosa per scalare quindi perfetto
il problema è che stage annuncerà che
cosa può scalare vabbè troveremo un modo
dio è stato uno dei jump square più
brutti della vita orribile ti fa avere
ragazzuoli direi che per oggi va bene
così è stato alquanto c'è più che altro
siamo andati avanti su quel punto lì e
mi interessava questo così che la
prossima volta che sasha torna scendiamo
insieme da quel punto torniamo dove
c'erano le capanne che ho anche messo il
check point come sulla tenda e da quel
punto lì andiamo avanti e vediamo che
cosa c'è dentro la caverna e che secondo
me è perfetto quindi ragazzuoli se
volete continuo lasciato un bel commento
mi piace al via pace di facebook e
crotone descrizione so se si discute il
civ il diavolo prossimo video e ragazzi